[music]
MÁIRTÍN JAMESIE: Pé ar bith céard eile
a gheall Dia do Mheáirt Mór Ó Cinnéide
Bhaile an Droichid, níor gheall
sé mórán foighide dhó.
Níl aon mhaidin ná aon tráthnóna
sa tseachtain nach bhfuil sé
ina chogadh dearg idir é fhéin
agus na beithígh. Sílim nach raibh
Cóilín a chanadh i bhfad as bealach
nuair a dúirt sé gur ar na beithígh
a bhronn Dia an fhoighid agus
gur ar Mheáirt fhéin a bhronn sé
an bhúiriúch. Tá an teist iontu le
cupla lá ach tá an vet le theacht
aríst inniu, go bhfeicfidh sé
ar síos nó suas a chuaigh siad.
[music]
[cows mooing and moving around]
MEÁIRT: Gabh isteach!
Gabh isteach! ... a dhiabhail!
MEÁIRT: [unintelligible shouting]
MEÁIRT: Nár thuga Dia slán
aníos amach.... *whistles* [?]Thíos, come on!...
[unintelligible shouting,
barking and cow noises]
MEÁIRT: Gabh isteach ansin
a dhiabhail, gabh isteach.
COLM: Lie down!
COLM: Fógair air a Mheáirt! Fógair air!
COLM: Ní fhágfaidh sé
buidéal ar tóin an phub!
MEÁIRT: Come back here you! Come back
here bitch! Right down a deirim leat!
COLM: Go on! Go on! Go on!
COLM: Á dhiabhail, á déanfaidh sí staggers...
déanfaidh sí staggers de bhuidéil...
MEÁIRT: Mallacht dílis Dé dhuit mar mhada.
Get out out of that!
WINNIE: Ach cén diabhal ná deamhan atá
ar an mbeirt agaibh chor ar bith?
[unintelligible shouting at animals]
MEÁIRT: Bhuel dhá mbeadh gunna agam, dhéanfainn
dhá leith de dhroim an mhada sin, agus
trí leath don ghaimhnín. Go out, a dhiabhail,
get out! Cén mhaith a deirinn dhuit a bheith
ag craith do dhrioball anois, nuair
atá an diabhal déanta agat?
COLM: Seas roimpe Winnie
maith an bhean.
COLM: Á dar Dia tiocfaidh sé isteach
thríd an bhfuinneog.
MEÁIRT: [unintelligible shouting]
MEÁIRT: ...dhiabhal eicínt,
ná bí i do sheasamh i do staic ansin!
WINNIE: Ah fágaigí an bealach an
bheirt agaibh, a dhá spleantair!
[unintellgible shouting, calling
at animals and animal sounds]
COLM: Ara muise a Winnie, tá do
cheird agat. Acha suas a Mheáirt!
COLM: Acha suas a dhiabhail ó chois go cois!
Gan gleo gan torann a Mheáirt!
COLM: Á, dar Dia, níl a fhios againn [...]
dhul i ndiaidh [...] a dheartháir.
WINNIE: Ní fhaca mé a dhá leiciméara ariamh
sa saol nach raibh ábalta rud eicínt a dhéanamh,
WINNIE: ach an bheirt agaibh.
Bhfuil mórán briste aige?
COLM: Ah, tá a fhios ag Dia go bhfuil,
a Winnie. Ach buidéil folamh iad.
MEÁIRT: Gabhfaidh mé leis an
diabhal de chosa mar bhullán.
WINNIE: Ah, ní dochar é. Nach
fearr briste iad ná cois duine.
COLM: Níl aon dochar ann, a Mheáirt,
an bhfuil a fhios agatsa go bhfuil
COLM: na buidéil bhriste sin thar cionn
in áit a mbeadh francaigh.
COLM: Staggers a dhéanamh dhaoibh
agus iad a scaoileadh síos sna poill.
COLM:  Ó, diabhal francach níos mó a Mheáirt.
WINNIE: Ara, fág ansin go fóilleach iad,
agus ólfaidh muid cupán tae.
COLM: Á tá a fhios ag Dia nach mbacfaidh mé leis,
a Winnie. Mar tá Mattie do m'iarraidh(?) ar an
COLM: chlár radio ar maidin, mar gheall ar
Oireachtas Rath Cairn. Is dar lán an leabhair
COLM: nuair atá baslach buailte
ar dhuine, is chaon tsórt,
COLM: ní aireoidh an t-am ag sciorradh a Winnie.
WINNIE: Bhuel, le cúnamh Dé, bhuel
ní bheidh sé i bhfad go bhfeicfidh mise
WINNIE: Rath Chairn. Ó cloisim
chuile dhuine dhá mholadh!
MEÁIRT: *coughs*
MEÁIRT: Níor fhága(?) chuile theach cattle crush.
Ní bhrisfidís mórán buidéal an uair sin.
COLM: Tá a fhios ag Dia muis, a Winnie,
go gcaithfidh tú a dhul ann. Bhuel a leithéide
COLM: de dheireadh seachtaine, mé fhéin
agus an mháistreás, agus bhí a bhainteach
COLM: in éineacht linn an créatúr.
MEÁIRT: Ah, ceann eile a bhfuil fonn rantáil
uirthi. Agus gan a fear bliain i dtalamh fós.
COLM: Ah, muise an créatúr, bhí sé in am aici
corraí amach. Chuirfeadh sí pian i do thóin.
COLM: Tá a fhios ag Mac Dia nach raibh mise
ag iarraidh corraí, murach máistreás na scoile.
COLM:  Ah, dar m'anam, nach dtiocfadh a Pheigí
a deirimse. Beidh an vet ag tíocht ag Meáirt,
COLM: a deirimse, is caithfidh mé láimh a
thabhairt dhó. Á, ní raibh an-mhaith a léamh...
MEÁIRT: Ah, joyrider eile.
COLM: Á, diabhal maith a bhí ann.
Diabhal a miste liom mar sin a deirimse,
COLM: ara is fad an t-aistear é, a Mheáirt,
á diabhal a leithéide de phíosa
COLM:  shaothraigh mé ariamh. Ní
dhriveáileadh máistreás na scoile sin
COLM: carr asail a Winnie. Sílim, slán
an tsamhail, go bhfuil a cosa róghearr
COLM: le meáchan ceart a chur ar na ceaipeannaí.
MEÁIRT: Huh, tá a teanga sách fada muis.
COLM: Ach is í an bhaintreach a dhriveáil abhaile.
M'anam gurb in í an cailín a bhain an deatach aisti.
COLM: Á dar Dia, is fhearr dhom rith. Tá sé
thar am radio a Winnie, lá maith agaibh.
WINNIE: Go dtuga Dia slán
abhaile thú, a Chóilín.
MEÁIRT: Tabharfaidh, a mh'anam,
mar diabhal Dia ná duine
MEÁIRT: ag iarraidh an bhruíon sin.
Caith síos braon tae, a Winnie!
MEÁIRT: gCeapann tú go bhfuil béal ar bith ormsa?
[music]
MÁIRTÍN JAMESIE: Tá Baile an Droichid
ar fad ag faire ar an mbaintreach
MÁIRTÍN JAMESIE: mar a bheadh cat
ag faire ar luch. Ní raibh dé ná deatach
MÁIRTÍN JAMESIE: le bliain uirthi, ó fuair
a fear bás, ach le cupla mí anuas,
MÁIRTÍN JAMESIE: tá sí fhéin agus
máistreás na scoile fíorluaineach.
[music]
PEGGIE: Ó, Jesus a Phil, we can't go this
meeting gan frigging idea eicínt againn!
PHIL: Breathnaigh, a Pheggie, déanfaidh muid
drama barrúil a bhainfeas gáirí amach.
PHIL: Tá mé fed up den dryrot seo,
Shakespeare agus Beckett, ara uch
PHIL: Christ chuirfidís
pian i do leath deiridh.
PEGGIE: Bhuel is é an idea atá agamsa
a Phil, ná dráma worthwhile.
PEGGIE: Tiocfadh daoine ag breathnú air,
agus d'fhéadfadh muid a dhul ag na
PEGGIE: drama festivals
ar fud na tíre leis.
PEGGIE: Bheadh an chraic
mighty againn Phil.
PHIL: Ní dóigh liomsa go bhfuil agat ach
dhá choice. John B. Keane nó
PHIL: Johnny Chóil Mhaidhc. Sin iad atá
feiliúnach d'aisteoirí faoin tuath.
PEGGIE: Seans go bhfuil tú ceart. Imagine
Meáirt mór ag tógáil páirt Shakespeare.
PEGGIE: "Friends, Romans, countrymen,
lend me your cattle crush!".
PEGGIE, WINNIE: Hahaha!
PEGGIE: Hahaha! Now, Winnie the penny mar leading actress!
[laughter]
PHIL: Á, stop. Ah bhfuil a fhios agat, is é
an faitíos atá ormsa a Pheggie go dtógfadh
PHIL: an sagart an meeting over.
Tá a fhios agat é siúd, tá sé a cheapadh
PHIL: gur invalids iad
an chuid eile againn.
PEGGIE: Bhuel, over my dead body.
Breathnaigh, ní thabharfaidh muid
PEGGIE: an seans dhó. Mol thusa mise
mar chathaoirleach, agus molfaidh mise
PEGGIE: thusa mar rúnaí.
PHIL: Right, right! Cuirfidh
muide beagáinín life isteach
PHIL:  i mBaile an Droichid á mbuíochas!
PEGGIE: Haha.
PHIL: An olfaidh tú hot whiskey?
PEGGIE: Why not, a dheirfiúr? Beidh muid sách fada caillte.
[music]
[door being opened and then closed]
WINNIE: Anois a Mheáirt, suigh síos ansin.
WINNIE: Tá píosa cainte le déanamh
ag an mbeirt againne.
MEÁIRT: Seo, níl sé d'am suí agam a Winnie.
Caithfidh mé na beithígh a ligean amach.
WINNIE: Suigh síos a Mheáirt. Caithfear
é seo a phlé, luath nó mall.
MEÁIRT: Á seo, seo, seo, abair pé ar bith
céard atá le rá agat
MEÁIRT: ná bí i bhfad eile ag baoiteáil leis!
WINNIE: An bhfuil tú ag éisteacht
liom anois? Bhí Michael ar an bhfón
WINNIE: as Londain aríst aréir.
MEÁIRT: Ó, Michael aríst. Michael. Sin é
a n-airím chuile lá. Má bhí anois,
MEÁIRT: labhair leis, mar níl
mise ag dul a labhairt leis.
MEÁIRT: An bleaigeard bradach!
Tá mé náirithe aige sin!
WINNIE: Ó, caill an cloigeann anois aríst!
Ní fhaca mé a leathfhear ariamh
WINNIE: nach mbeadh foighid aige ach dhó.
Is é do mhacsa é, a Mheáirt, an t-aon mhac
WINNIE: atá agat, agus an t-aon
mhac a bheas agat!
MEÁIRT: Ba dh'é mo mhac é a Winnie, ach
is é mac an diabhail anois é!
WINNIE: Is é mo mhacsa freisin é, ach
má tá rud as bealach fhéin déanta aige,
WINNIE: tá cion agam air. Mar ní fearacht
go leor eile, ní fhág sé ansin í.
WINNIE: Tá flat ag an mbeirt acu,
agus tá siad ag maireachtáil
WINNIE: go sona sásta lena chéile.
MEÁIRT: Ó go sábhála Mac Dílis Dé sinn
orthu! Ag maireachtáil lena chéile?
MEÁIRT: Gan pósadh gan ceangal?
Ó a leithéide de scannal!
MEÁIRT: Beidh mé náirithe aige!
WINNIE: Nár chaith tusa amach as
an teach i ndiaidh a mhullaigh é?
WINNIE: Ní ag cuartú abortion
a chuaigh siad, mar a rinne go leor eile.
WINNIE: Is graíúla iad fhéin ná
go leor dhá bhfuil ag traipseáil
WINNIE: síos ag an altóir
chuile Dhomhnaigh.
WINNIE: Agus tá siad ag teacht abhaile faoin Nollaig.
MEÁIRT: Ó, fanaidís i dtigh diabhail
san áit a bhfuil siad! Níl siad ag dul
MEÁIRT: ag déanamh bodyhouse
den teach seo, tá mise ag rá leat!
WINNIE: Dia dhá réiteach...
[music]
MÁIRTÍN JAMESIE: Ach oiread le baile,
ní facthas gardaí chomh luaineach
i mBaile an Droichid le fada an lá agus
atá siad le seachtain. Níl poll ná prochóig
ná tom nach bhfuil tóraithe acu, agus
ar ndóigh nádúrtha go leor, tá amhras
ar chuile strainséara. Thíos le cladach atá
Parthalán Mac an tSionnaigh ag cur faoi,
is amhlaidh atá teach ar cíos aige ann,
teach beag samhraidh le Peatsaí Pheaits
Dhonncha, atá ina chontractóir i Sasana
le blianta. Is iondúil le bean Pheatsaí
agus a n-iníon Helen an samhradh a chaitheamh
sa teachín fada seo, ach ní bhíonn sé d'am
ag Peatsaí fhéin mórán saoire a thógáil
chor ar bith. Ach ina dhiaidh sin fhéin,
bíonn fonn air an teach a ligean le
daoine an chuid eile den bhliain,
mar a deir sé fhéin, ní hé an t-airgead
fhéin é, ach coinneoidh sé tine ann.
[music]
GARDA: This is it, lads. Don't take
any chances. He may be armed.
GARDA: This is a garda raid. Open the door
slowly and come out with your hands up.
PARTHALÁN: Cé atá... cé atá ansin? Tá...
táim ag teacht! Táim ag teacht.
[door opening]
PARTHALÁN: Cé atá ansin? Alright.
Ó a thiarcais, cad... cad é seo?
GARDA: Ní "cad" ar bith é. Keep your hands up.
PARTHALÁN: Tá dearmad mór anseo.
Níl aon rud as bealach déanta agam.
GARDA: Cuartaigh é leaids.
PARTHALÁN: Whoa! Stop é seo! Mo chuid
éadach... leapan atá orm!
PARTHALÁN: Níl... níl cead agat é seo
a dhéanamh! Tá... tá mise ag obair anseo.
GARDA: Dá mbeifeá, in éadach coladh
a bheifeá an t-am seo de mhaidin.
GARDA: Cén t-ainm atá ort?
PARTHALÁN: Parthalán Mac an tSionnaigh.
Oifigeach de chuid an Rialtais.
GARDA: Agus céard atá tú
a dhéanamh sa gceantar seo?
PARTHALÁN: Suirbhé ar... ar Ghaeilge.
GARDA: Bullshit. Oifigeach de chuid an IRA,
b'fhéidir. Ag tabhairt gunnaí i dtír
GARDA: is á gcur i bhfolach, cuirfidh mé geall.
PARTHALÁN: Tá an fear mícheart agat. Tá
obair fíorthábhachtach le déanamh agamsa.
PARTHALÁN: Tá daoine sa ceantar seo ag
labhairt focail Béarla agus tá siad ag loit
PARTHALÁN: na Gaeilge.
Drochghramadach freisin.
GARDA: Óra seafóid, ní chreidim focal uait.
Handcuffs leaids. Tá tú ag dul go dtí
GARDA: Tá tú ag dul go dtí an beairic.
PARTHALÁN: Níl aon rud cearr déanta agamsa.
Ní féidir leat mé a ghabháil gan barántas.
GARDA: Is féidir liom thú a chaitheamh
isteach sa mblack hole ar feadh
GARDA: ocht uaire agus dhá fhichead chun tú
a cheistiú mar gheall ar sceimhleoireacht.
GARDA: Cuir air na handcuffs leaids.
PARTHALÁN: Ach níl aon bhríste orm! Tabhair
seans dhom mo bhríste a chur orm.
PARTHALÁN: Beidh aiféal ort, tabharfaidh
mé cás clúmhilleadh i do choinne.
PARTHALÁN: Tabhair seans dhom mo chuid éadaí a chur orm.
GARDA: B'fhéidir gur beag seans a thug tú
féin do dhaoine, amach anseo sa squadcar...
GARDA: [unintelligible]
PARTHALÁN: Beidh raic, beidh raic mar gheall air seo!—
[unintelligible]
[music]